again tonight though with a Fox News
Alert a bombshell new report from The
Wall Street Journal has now exposed a
blatant dual system of justice at Joe
Biden's Department of Justice tonight we
are learning that the justice department
rejected a federal search for top secret
classified documents housed at Joe
Biden's many properties the they called
off the FBI no raid for Joey Joe Biden
gets different treatment than Trump and
said they Outsource the search to
Biden's own private attorneys and Biden
staffers including many without any
security clearance at all whatsoever now
in the case of the private attorneys
well they can now be Witnesses in a
criminal investigation and according to
Jonathan Turley who will join us in a
moment quote the use of private Council
without clearances following the first
discovery could itself be viewed as
Reckless and gross mishandling but at
this point Biden's doj doesn't really
seem to care because quote Mr Biden's
attorneys had quickly turned over a
first batch and they were cooperating
right they quickly turned over a first
batch
six years after the documents were taken
uh from their rightful home of course
the same leniency was never in the cards
for Donald Trump remember the former
president was cooperating with Federal
officials inquiring about documents
potentially at Mar-A-Lago he invited
them to his home he allowed unfettered
access to the documents FBI agents
actually were free and clear and went in
the room where the documents eventually
were found and they never asked for them
even though they were there Trump then
secured the documents with a padlock in
that room at their request and yet in
the early morning hours of August the
8th a talked a tactical team from the
FBI raided Mar-A-Lago guns drawn as they
searched through melania's closet and
Baron's bedroom and they left no stone
unturned and took whatever they wanted
by force and that include include the
president's passport by the way the
Attorney General mayor Carlin the FBI
director Ray they said and bragged about
signing off on this raid at Mar-A-Lago
but they were unwilling to do the same
for Joe Biden by the way why didn't they
tell us when they knew six days before
the midterm elections now apparently
they want you and all of us to just
trust that Joe Biden and his attorneys
and his aides are going to do the right
thing but Joe Biden almost never does
the right thing he is a notorious liar
with very few principles or morals he
won't even acknowledge his own
four-year-old granddaughter or Grant her
a secret service protection but we're
just supposed to take his word for it in
this document investigation now remember
it is now well established that Joe
Biden as vice president met with at
least 14 of Hunter Biden's sketchy
foreign business partners he then flat
out lied repeatedly about those meetings
denied any knowledge of ever even
speaking to his son about his foreign
business ventures now of course Joe
Biden was the centerpiece of those
Ventures as Hunter admitted in an
interview on ABC see take a look in the
list you gave me of the reasons why
you're on that board you did not list
the fact that you were the son of course
yeah no what role do you think that
played I think that it is impossible for
me to be on any of the boards that I
just mentioned without saying that I'm
the son of the Vice President of the
United States if your last name wasn't
Biden do you think you would have been
asked to be on the board of barisma I
don't know I don't know probably not I
don't think that there's a lot of things
that would have happened in my life that
uh that if my last name wasn't
in that very interview he admitted he
had no experience at oil or gas or
energy or Ukraine or the energy sector
at all or sophisticated investing
absolutely no experience uh zero
experience Hunter was selling access to
his dad that's called influence peddling
it has a real name and in 2017 when
Hunter was still raking in money from
many of these sketchy foreign business
partners a document obtained by Miranda
Devine and the Daily Caller shows that
Joe Biden was purportedly collecting
fifty thousand dollars in rent per month
at his Delaware home from his own son
why now it's not Palm Beach and it's not
you know Malibu California now this is
true and Hunter was actually paying pops
50 Grand a month to rent a room in
Delaware that I think we all know how
the big guy was taking his cut and get
this according to a report from John
Solomon Hunter and at least one of his
business associates they discussed Joe
Biden's earnings potential and wealth
creation in an email chain titled jrb
future jrb stands for Joseph Robinette
Biden and apparently the future plans
heavily involve the Communist Party of
China not only did China contribute tens
and tens of millions of dollars to the
University of Pennsylvania after the
establishment of the Biden Center 67
million in total to the university
47.7 million once Joe Biden was out of
office but hunter also scored a
lucrative deal with the Chinese energy
firm and that included that 5 million
dollar interest-free forgivable loan
this was in addition to the one hundred
thousand dollar shopping spree with the
Chinese National and by the way we can't
forget the multi-billion dollar
sweetheart deal with the Bank of China
no explanation why they didn't go to
Goldman Sachs JP Morgan uh Deutsche Bank
or maybe a real firm so yeah top secret
documents lying around at the UPenn
Center and in Joe's Garage and in his
library and in his other house that's
deeply concerning but according to many
in the MOB the media and Democrats ah
it's no big deal at all we just have to
trust Joe Biden they only have one true
Boogeyman in all of this and his name
when all else fails and the dog bites
and the bee stings and you're feeling
sad you gotta blame Donald Trump take a
look and the intelligence Community
needs to do its risk and damage
assessment about how Donald Trump's very
Reckless handling of these documents
might have harmed our national security
they find the documents they reported
immediately a four different situation
than Donald Trump's anybody who says
it's not is a political hack if the
Trump people represented that they
provided all the classified or national
security information and didn't that's a
serious problem as far as we can tell
that it was inadvertent that these
documents were in these locations when
they were discovered they were
immediately provided to the archives or
to the justice department there was no
effort to hold on to them no effort to
conceal them this was not a mistake that
these documents landed you know at
Mar-A-Lago this is what he intended and
it also by the way shows that they
really want to get these documents back
and every second that they're at this
beach house in the possession of Donald
Trump is a risk to our national security
well he should have said you look I know
I look hypocritical in that tape yeah
I'm so sorry about that
by the way all those people are all
political hacks now luckily we have an
honest press secretary with a very solid
grasp of the facts who's committed to
transparency only kidding over the last
two weeks Kareem Jean-Pierre has sadly
embarrassed herself over and over as she
has attempted again and again to
Stonewall the press and has told
um let's just charitably call them
untruths to the American people take a
look what I can tell you right now is
what the president is is uh share with
you what the president said to all of
you right which is he was surprised by
this he definitely truly respects uh the
process here uh and also when it comes
to classified he takes classified
documents very seriously that that
search was
and now this is
it
you should assume that it's been
completed yes wait they completed uh the
uh the search with documents being found
last night I have answered your
questions uh as almost every day on this
issue and again anything else that you
may have anything that's related to the
review I would refer you to the
Department of Justice you guys can ask
me this 100 times 200 times if you wish
I'm going to keep saying the same thing
are you upset that you came out to this
Podium on Friday with incomplete and
inaccurate information and are you
concerned that it affects your
credibility up here what I'm what I'm
concerned about is making sure that we
do not politically interfere in the
Department of Justice that we continue
to be consistent over the last two years
and uh and that is continue to refer you
all when it comes to an ongoing process
and uh and I'll just leave it there
so obviously we're not going to hear the
truth from the Biden Administration in
any way that's why investigations in the
house are critically important hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else